Bob has taken back drum and turns out she's allergic to it.
The last dose of back drum was week and a half ago.
She's still experiencing intense symptoms
and she's been in the hospital twice.
Any recommendations, how to get this out of her system?
She's on a probiotic to help her gut now.
Yeah, it's hard when you have an allergic reaction
to a medication because the allergic reaction
to the medication can linger for a long time.
And part of the reason it could linger for a long time
is because you might have actually, so let's take a step back.
A lot of people will go, we need to detox that medication.
We're going to support detoxification pathways
and try to get that medication out of the system.
It could be lingering in the tissues.
It could be still causing problems.
That can be true.
But why do some people after a medication
or some source of exposure to something seemingly
continue to have symptoms long periods of time afterwards?
The answer to that really lies in that allergic reaction
to that medication did to the person.
The truth is there may be nothing more to detoxify.
That may be gone if there may not even be a way to find out.
But if there was a way to find out, that product might not
be in the person's system anymore.
Why would they still be having problems?
Because it stimulated a reaction.
It stimulated in a flammatory reaction.
And that in flammatory reaction just
upticked that person's current issue that they had
that was lying dormant.
And a perfect example of that is what I was just discussing
a few minutes ago with neuroinflammation.
If you have microglial, prime microglial cells in the brain,
and of course this is gibberish unless you watch that video.
So go to codersclinic.com search for neuroinflammation.
Watch the 30 minute video.
I explained microglial cells.
What they are in the brain, they're the brain's immune system.
If they become damaged, they can become damaged
from a myriad of different reasons.
And you could have basically not an idea that that has taken place
because you have credited your symptoms to other things.
You have other diseases.
You have other problems.
But it can be stemming from microglial primate.
And so if you have prime microglial cells,
anything can trigger prime microglial cells
to go into this state that's called this inflamed state,
this M1 state.
So they stay in this inflamed state
and they're just spewing out inflammatory cytokines.
When they're doing that, depending on where
these microglial cells are in your brain,
they can affect you in all sorts of different ways.
If they're the pridal lobes of the brain,
they're going to affect your sensory nervous system
so they can cause pain and inflammation
in various parts of the body.
If they're in your motor cortex,
they're going to cause motor issues.
You're going to have issues with function issues
with muscle function issues with coordination.
They're in your cerebellum.
You're going to major coordination issues.
If they're in your prefrontal cortex,
you're going to have thought process and cloudy thinking
and so depending on where your brain controls everything.
So if you have inflammation areas
that are in your brain that are spewing out
inflammatory cytokines,
you could have just a myriad of different types of symptoms.
Highly suggest you look at that
because there's ways to colon that down.
So it may not be that you have to detox the poison anymore.
It's what the poison did to your body
that you have to calm down.
So in that video, I list taking flavonoids
and being careful with exercise and zero alcohol
and some general detoxification support
and stimulating parasympathetic nervous systems.
So there's all sorts of different recommendations
that I go through on that.
So just understand anything can trigger that.
So you could be living a fairly healthy life
and you pay your head.
And now your life is just completely changed.
So this is where lots of times people come to us
and they say my life changed completely when this happened.
When I took this medication, I reacted.
When I had a car accident, I had a concussion.
My life has never been the change.
Never been the same.
You have to think this person has microglial primate
or worse, this person has auto antibodies to neural tissue.
We need to find the triggers, calm it down.
We need to calm down that inflammation
and get to the source of this.
That would be my biggest recommendation
to try to get to the source of what's really causing the problem.